euh on va maintenant parler euh de cette
autre affaire euh regardez voir c'est un
supporter tué par un chauffeur VTC à NES
que s'est-il passé regardez les images
et on aa un témoin dans un instant c'est
parti regardez une fresque à sa mémoire
des bouquets de fleurs les hommages
s'accumulent sur les lieux même où le
supporter du FC Nantes a perdu la vie
samedi soir sur les images d'une caméra
fixée à bord d'un véhicule on voit la
scène du crime pas de légitime défense
pour le chauffeur VTC qui a poignardé
Maxime 31 ans l'arme n'a pas été
retrouvé à ce stade rien n'est retenu
contre les supporters ni soit alors euh
Michel justement qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé à N on a un témoin avec nous ce
soir David tan chauffeur VTC merci
d'être avec nous David parce que c'est
vrai que cette histoire tout le monde en
a parlé aujourd'hui et on sait pas trop
ce qui s'est passé mais c'est il y a eu
quand même un drame bah c'est un drame
oui parce qu'un homme est mort un
supporter est mort alors que c'était a
priori une fête une fête sportive ça a
fini dans un dans un bain de sang ce qui
se passe en fait ce soir-là vers 19h5
au niveau du du stade enfin 2 300 m du
stade de de Nantes le stade de
beaujoir on a un convoi de
VTC dans lequel se trouvent des
supporters niissois sont une trentaine
en gros avec 5 ou si ou peut-être 7
véhicules et ils avancent vers le stade
ils vont ils vont assister au match et
ils sont pris à parti par environ 200
supporters Nanta qui étai d'une violence
incroyable qui ont commencé à casser les
voitures casser les parebrises casser
les carreaux mettre des coups de pieds
dans les voitures enfin ils ont ils se
sont conduit de façon de façon très
violente et le chauffeur d'un des VTC à
un moment donné sort de son véhicule en
sortant de son véhicule il il
déverrouille l'intégralité du de son de
sa voiture du coup les supporters
niissois se sont fait tabasser à
l'intérieur puisque c'était ouvert enfin
il suffisait de tirer la porte ils sont
fait tabasser euh et le chauffeur de de
ce VTC est revenu quelques secondes
après à l'intérieur de son de son
véhicule et il avait un couteau à la
main ça c'est les trois clients les
trois supporters qui qui le qui
l'affirment qui qui en témoignent il
avait un couteau à la main et il a
d'ailleurs fait le commentaire en disant
je crois que j'ai planté un mec dans le
dos
euh ensuite il va mettre à l'amende les
trois clients en leur demandant d'aller
au distributeur automatique de billets
pour sortir 300 € chacun afin de
rembourser les frais
occasionnés sur le véhicule les
dégradations occasionnées sur le sur le
véhicule c'est quo cette histoire
d'extorsion avec arbre bah c'est ça ça
c'est ça et c'est quoi cette histoire de
deè de deuxème chauffeur qui détruit
l'épreuve alors il y avait a priori un
deuxième chauffeur qui était sans doute
un copain du premier euh qui se trouvait
derrière et maintenant les VTC sont
équipés de de caméras de vidéo ce qui
fait que le le 2e VTC a filmé la une
partie de la scène sauf que lorsqu'il
enfin ils sont tous les deux constitués
prisonniers à des moments différents
lorsqu'ils se présentent au commissariat
de police de Nantes les policiers
cherchent la les images vidéos ne les
trouvent pas et donc il les a dissimulé
d'accord alors que montre les vidéos
trouvées par la police alors les
policiers vont faire une perquisition au
domicile de ce de chauffeur et ils vont
retrouver les les cartes sur lesquelles
les images sont enregistrées et alors là
c'est c'est quand même incroyable parce
que sur ces images qui ont été
visionnées par les enquêteurs on voit
clairement la scène se dérouler et là le
chauffeur le premier chauffeur celui qui
avait le couteau à la main dans le dans
dans son VTC il avait un système de
défense qui consistait à dire qu'il
savait pas du tout où était le couteau
que c'était pas à lui et cetera on le
voit le couteau à la main mais on le
voit surtout en train de se battre avec
le fameux supporter Mathieu je crois qui
est décédé euh max Maxime pardon merci
euh on le voit avec aux prises avec
Maxime Maxime tombe au sol et à ce
moment-là ce chauffeur va lui assainer
deux coups de couteau un premier coup de
couteau quand il est au sol et un
deuxième coup de couteau quand le
supporter prend la fuite et ça les
images malheureusement enfin elles sont
elles sont criantes de vérité alors
justement David tan chauffeur VTC vous y
étiez racontez-nous ce que vous avez
vécu alors tout d'abord la véracité des
propos sont véridiques puisque c'est
procureur don qui l'a dit ce soir je
suis sur le plateau déjà en tant que
chauffeur VTC en mon nom on adresse
quand même les condoléances à la famille
de Max et aux supporteurs de du stade de
Nant parce qu'on est tous
supporters aujourd'hui j'ai de la peine
c'est vrai le hasard c'est que c'est moi
qui est en tête de
convoi aujourd'hui je vais l'ultra
violence des
individus que ça soit des supporters ou
des gens cagoulés je prends l'initiative
d'être devant je roule effectivement le
bar de saint-georgees bizarrement il y
avit pas grand monde j'arrive devant
j'ai un véhicule typé anglais il y a la
fête à l'intérieur de mon véhicule les
supporteurs nois ils sont contents ils
sont six à bord de mon véhicule et quand
j'arrive je trouve étonnamment une nuée
d'individu noir devant moi sur la
chaussée la voix qui arrive et la voix
qui recule dans dans quartier de la
beauoire les jeunes hommes me dit avance
avance je fais non je sais qui c'est qui
en face de moi je m'arrête je baisse la
vitre je fais les arrê de déconner et là
ça tape ça tape ça casse mon parbr
justement ça veut ouvrir la portière
elle est antagoniste les C anglais vous
ouvrez et quand j'avance bah la porte
s'ouvre à 90 referm referm heureusement
il avent les ceintures y en a deux
denissois qui tire leur copains ma porte
est dégondée mais j'avance
malheureusement moi je bouscule des gens
et à mon temps il y a un jeune qui tape
sur mon calandre il tape mon Parise il
tombe et moi je lui roule dessus donc je
suis fautif j'arrive on va trouver
secours au poste de police on leur dit
venez venez parce que moi dans mon
rétroviseur je vois mes camarades
justement qui sont aussi pris à parti
donc une nué de 20 sur 10 lignes ça fait
au moins 200 donc j'ai dit 300 on peut
faire
100 il y a un
drame toutes les semaines tous les jours
il y a des des morts
le fait est que la personne qui est
incriminée est mon collaborateur on
travaille ensemble c'est ça j'étais pas
au courant que c'était lui parce que moi
quand je me dénonce à la police je pense
que c'est moi la police elle est là avec
le tokiy détresse respiratoire malaise
cardiaque pensez que c'est le gars que
vous avez écrasé écrasé ok je reste
l'agent de police me dit vous vous
restez RG me dit on va prendre votre nom
et quand ils entendent sur les ones arme
blanche donc il se retourne vers moi il
me dit monsieur vous avez une arme
couteau non moi je suis resté dans mon
véhicule pour sauver mes passagers moi
j'ai avancé les autres effectivement ils
avaient plus de place pour ouvrir et
cetera il y avait trois véhicules et les
trois derniers
voyant l'embrouille ils ont fait
demi-tour ils sont partis donc des trois
derrière se sont sauvés les trois du
milieu là tant pis pour ils sont pris et
moi je je pars j'appelle ce fameux mise
en cause je lui dis ouais je me suis
fait cayassé défoncé lui aussi il me
parle je comprends pas il y a la lumière
de la nuit et cetera chacun fait ce
qu'ils ont à faire je dis à l'agent de
police il me dit bah allez au
commissariat mais comme si
tranquillement porte t plaintes pour
dégradation de véhicule mais moi je je
je préviens mon avocat je dis ça se trou
je vais y rester pendant mon audition à
23h50 j'apprends le décès de du
supporter donc moi je suis effondré
parce que c'est notre équipe notre bien
sûr je refais l'effet ça fait 3 4 jours
je vais pas in criminer qui que ce soit
la préfecture le manque de sécurité
notre faute à nous de pas avoir suivi un
itinéire il y a plein
d'événements maintenant qu'est-ce que
vous attendez vous venez attaquer un
convoi bah attendez-vous aussi à une
réplique nous on n'est pas né VTC
monsieur Hanouna moi j'y réfléchis je
vais me marier dans 6 mois je non si si
je sors et que je ch un gaz ou ma
matraque c'est mort j'ai j'ai vu les
visages des mec j'ai parlé qu'est-ce que
tu fais je sais qui c'est non
trace je voulais pas faire
bowling je connais la tragédie du du 14
juillet à Nice moi j'avance
maintenant j'étais le chauffeur c'est
encore le hasard sur les raisons on me
dit je veux faire du buzz non j'tais mon
travail je rentis chez moi moi on m'a
dit fait une dernière mission les RG
m'appelle monsieur vous devez déposer
j'appelle tous mes camarades sur notre
groupe WhatsApp venez venez venez
collègue VTC oui qui est à l'origine du
qui est présumé meurter de de de Maxime
est-ce que vous avez est-ce que vous
avez compris
son ce qu'il a fait son geste
aujourd'hui je je je sais pas j'ai
pas comment voilà parce que ce que j'ai
expliqué moi je me mets à imaginer que
il y a SEP scénarios chacun gér ce qu'il
pouvait malheureusement il y a un
couteau l'autre collègue il avait une
matraque il a voulait effacer les
preuves il voulait se protéger est-ce
que c'est la légitime défense moi
j'étais parti sur ce terrain là on on le
voit d'ailleurs avec la matraque sur les
images vidéos le deuxè he en train de
taper sur les sur les manifestant mais
il il s'est fait déjà sortir son
véhicule avant j'ai juste une petite
question vous poser je sais que le
chauffeur votre copain a appelé
plusieurs autres chauffeurs pour leur
dire qu'il avait eu un incident une
altercation et qu'il avait donné des
coups de couteau est-ce qu'il vous a dit
ça à vous mais je vous dis dans mon dans
ma mémoire comme moi j'étais terrorisé
et c'est ça le comment on va dire ça le
l'incompréhension parce que moi-même
j'étais choqué mais d'accord mais il
vous l'a dit ou vous l'a pas dit non moi
moi il me'a pas dit d'accord moi je
l'entends pas d'accord vous l'avez pas
entendu parce que je je pense qu'il a dû
me dire ouais mon pare-brise j'ai je
peux pas dire le mot je dis si vous avez
dit j'ai planté un coup de couteau dans
le
dos parce que sinon je va pas me livrer
j'ai il y a un collègue il a fait
la version du monsieur c'est la version
du chauffeur d'ailleurs incriminé qui
est mis en examen pour homicide
volontaire précisons-le et d'ailleurs
lui dit qu'il n'avait pas l'intention de
tuer mais le procureur a balayé sa
théorie en disant que la légitime
défense ne tient pas parce qu'il y ça
vous savez aussi monsieur il faut il
faut monsieur gilverdez je reviens pas
sur cette affaire aller sur enquête je
suis venu là pour parler de ma terreur
du choc émotionnel mais cette on vous
avez eu peur pour votre vie ou pas bien
sûr vous savez 93 nous quartier nord de
Nant j'en ai eu un des embrouill on a la
même génération on aard on a vous allez
vous marier bi quand tu fais des fights
vous allez vous marier bientôt ouais
j'ai mis le côté qu non mais je connais
aussi les individus des classes
sportifes sil veulent se retrouver pour
se Fighter va un endroit mais on va pas
rouler devant le Saint-George on va pas
se mettre à côté des CRS qui sont à côté
David David j'ai l'impression que vous
saviez pas trop quoi faire vous avez dit
qu'est-ce que je fais est-ce que je moi
moi j'avais une solution c'est devant ça
mais je vous dis c'est moi le premier
les autres ils sont presque arrêtés et
puis ça vient comme ça moi j'ai 200
personnes
là jamais vu ça de ma vie donc vous
voyez les émeutes qu'on voit la télé les
machins ah ouais c'est ça les vrais
trucs nous on est là dans notre canap on
regarde ah ouais c'est pourquoi elle a
fait ça ce guignol non quand vous y êtes
vous avez une réaction vous avez 30
secondes pour agir è d'accord avec Dav
moi je suis un chauffeur euh euh j'ai
des clients donc tu dois prendre une
décision très vite bah oui mon outil de
travail mon intégrité physique les gens
qui sont en face tes clients à protéger
aussi voilà moi c'est pas des voyous il
y a pas d'affrontement dire ouais toi je
vais non j'ai mais qu'est-ce j'ai envoyé
la vidéo à votre rédacteur bien s je
vous dis à vous tous regarder top driver
serv sur Youtube vous allez voir comment
je travaille moi c'est festif il y a une
boule à facette musique les jeunes
hommes ils ont il ils sortai la barre
ils buvaient encore dans mon véhicule
bah votre carré de boule et tout on pas
de dire on va on va taper rien du tout
ou ouais c'est ça maintenant il y a un
il y a un mort je le pleure bien sûr je
connaissais pasine je vais vous dire il
y a quelqu'un qui m'a téléphoné il
comprenait pas l'histoire on a pris 45
minutes pour discuter tous les deux là
il a dit voilà donc je mets pas je vais
pas donner de nom des individus cagoulé
vêtu de noir qui agresse un convoi de
VTC voyez ce jeune homme là mais moi
j'ai cru l'Éc ah oui je sais il met un
coup de pome dans mon radiateur il fait
une galipette il tape mon mon parbrise
mais il glisse sur le cap il est devant
moi donc là qu'est-ce qu'on fait
maintenant avec les gouvernements la
violence l'ultra violence se taper entre
supporters nous chauffeurs on passe pour
des voyou vous connaissez tous les
problèmes on me dit armée armée armée
non moi j'ai une gazuse moyen de de
protection bien sûr on est des espèces
sur
nous l'affaire est en cours g je vouleis
pas vous je veux pas revenir sur ça
merci David voilà attendez un soutien
quand même à notre collègue malgré ce
qu'il fait on va le soutenir parce que
çaur être moi moi si j'aurais ma demie
en disant je m'en fous excusez-moi du
terme je vais les parce que c'est
le mot j'ai malheureusement j'ai
plusieurs véhicules moi dans ma société
j'ai TR dashcam le nouveau que j'ai j'ai
pas eu le temps de la
mettre j'ai qure téléphones dans ma
voiture j'aurais pu continuer à filmer
au moment qu'il arrivaient ça filmait
je suis navré pour ce soir je viens sur
un plateau ça être la dernière le
dernier média que je fais merci je l'ai
dit à tout le monde je dis à mes
collaborateur ch TR j'ai l'alarme parce
que
ça je connais pas ce Maxime il reviendra
plus mais jeun hommes il reviennent plus
donc c'est des familles runées le
gouvernement il fait quoi moi je voulais
attaquer l'arrêté préfectoral au
tribunal administratif on a 2 mois pour
dénoncer je l'ai lu A à Z ils ont même
fait une faute il il écit Olympique de
Marseille il SAV qu' un conflit le 12
mars 2023 10 ultra Nant ils ont tabassé
TR nissois ça veut dire quoi on continue
lorsque a le match retour ah non non on
fait quoi donc excusez-moi messieurs
dames c'est P de fites vous excuse David
et merci d'avoir été là et bon j'espère
que le mariage va bien se passer en tout
cas merci beaucoup David d'avoir été
avec nous tout de suite c'est gens le FA